we're all going to die according to the
libs
your children are going to die from the
wuflu if they don't take the fouchy
auchi women
are going to die from back alley
abortions if the supreme court overrules
roe versus wade and black people and
homosexuals are definitely going to die
in vicious hate crimes every time they
leave their homes if people draw the
wrong conclusions from the jesse smilet
hoax
all of those fears are bogus but the
libs are right about one thing
we are all going to die at some point
we've been dying since the day we were
born and a lot of our present
dysfunction comes from our refusal to
admit it i'm michael knowles this is the
michael nols show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from sharon
bisriges who says it's okay
everyone makes mistakes jesse
don't beat yourself up
you know the one that was going around
everyone was
was tweeting out like hey i'm so glad
jesse smallett's attacker was finally
brought to justice you know i saw like
500 versions of that on the timeline but
that version i like better don't beat
yourself up jesse jesse juicy i don't
know we'll get to it
you know when you want to protect what
you're looking for online like if you're
looking to buy all sorts of things to
stage one of the greatest hoaxes in the
last several years in america or if
you're looking up good stuff or if
you're looking up just good true and
beautiful stuff that you don't want the
big tech people to find out about
you got to check out expressvpn do you
know that your internet service provider
knows every single website that you
visit
every single way and if you're listening
to this show you might
go to some websites you don't want other
people to know about you know you close
the blinds you turn on the incognito
window and you go to websites like
dailywire.com you know politically
incorrect ones that could get you
canceled from your job so don't let your
isp do this don't let them sell this
information to ad companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you
check out expressvpn they put a stop to
this they create a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone i love
expressvpn i use it on all my devices
it's super easy it's just one button you
install it you use it on your laptop you
use it on your cell phone it's so easy
especially if you're traveling and
people travel a lot around christmas
time if you're in an airport on public
wi-fi in a cafe don't open yourself up
to this folks if you're like me
and you think your online activity ought
to be your business secure yourself by
visiting expressvpn.com
michael today m-i-c-h-a-e-l
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l you
get an extra three months for free
expressvpn.com
michael
the children
the children you monsters are not
thinking of the children
so says dr fauci
if your child is five years of age and
older please get them vaccinated we need
to protect
the children this idea that children are
not vulnerable at all is not so george i
mean certainly statistically children do
not get as severe disease as the adults
particularly the elderly but if you look
at the number of cases of children now
well over two million children from five
to eleven have been infected they've
been over eight thousand to nine
thousand hospitalizations and well over
a hundred deaths the children the
children won't somebody please
think of
the children now dr fauci admits here
you've got when you listen to dr fauci
you gotta pay very close attention to
the words he uses he admits that
children have
an infinitesimally small chance of dying
from the coronavirus thank god that's so
wonderful the infection fatality rate
for children from the coronavirus is
around
0.003
at the high end it can be as low as
0.001 percent depending on exactly what
criteria you're looking at when you take
out children with
comorbidities children who are very
unhealthy who have other diseases who
are extremely overweight when you take
that out
the
infection fatality rate drops
significantly lower
infinitesimally
small so children are not really at that
kind of risk and dr fauci admits as much
but he says regardless
you got to get your child your children
need to get the
fauciouci or else you're a bad parent
and he's he knows that what do parents
care most about in the world it's their
children and so he's going to manipulate
them
and he's going to
become a dem he already is a demagogue
on this issue but he's going to push his
demagoguery even further
and he's going to completely
misrepresent the data sure children
don't get as severely uh infected but to
say that they have no
side effects or consequences from the
virus whatsoever that is false well no
one's saying that no one's saying
children aren't going to get a little
bit sick
but
getting a little bit sick is not the
reason to force an experimental drug
into everybody's arm and to shut down
the entire world for two years
right you need to have some prudence
here and and the data which vouchy is
even out of in between the words in
between the lines he's kind of admitting
the data don't back up his
fear-mongering so the children i think
they're going to be okay generally
speaking i think they're going to be
okay for now how about the women
kamala harris is very worried about the
women she says that if roe versus wade
is overruled
then
the women are going to die in the san
francisco chronicle she says quote i
don't mean to sound alarmist i mean this
women will die i'm very concerned about
it women will die in particular women
who don't have economic resources and
can't travel to places or somehow have
access to safe reproductive health care
including abortion and it is not an
extreme statement it is a fact so
especially poor women
if we let poor women have their babies
and we don't
have a society in which poor women are
encouraged to kill their babies
then those poor women might face some
consequences if they go get an illegal
abortion
she's not even saying poor poor women
are going to die or any women are going
to die from having a baby she's saying
that they're going to die from trying to
get illegal abortions but even that is
not true even that number is not true
we've mentioned it on the show before
but there was a lie being pushed by the
left that thousands of women were dying
every year before roe v wade from back
alley abortions and it's not true the
person who invented that bogus statistic
is dr bernard nathanson he was a
pro-abortion one of the co-founders of
the pro-abortion league he then became a
pro-lifer and admitted it was completely
made up and when you look at the data
from the federal government of the women
who died each year from the illegal
abortions it was less than 40. it was in
the 30s then when you look at the women
who died from legal abortions it was in
the 20s it was less less than 30 but it
was pretty similar when you look at the
number of states where abortion was
legal and illegal your chances of dying
from either were basically the same and
they were extremely talk about
infinitesimally small so it's just bogus
by the way that was in 1972.
how much more advanced has medical
technology gotten to save women's lives
if they have some kind of complication
from whatever illegal activity they're
doing
so it's just
just bogus it is completely made up it
is an outright lie that is still
shamelessly peddled been debunked a
zillion times and certainly what's her
kamala harris has no no shame about
lying she has she is a very very cynical
politician but i think the women
are going to be okay so now what about
what about we've taken care of the
children
we've taken care of the women what about
the black people and the homosexuals
because we are told we're told by lebron
james every time a black man walks out
his front door he's being hunted down by
racist whites
we're in the case of justice millet
racist
nigerians
racist homophobic gay nigerians that
that's who is hunting down
black
homosexual
people jesse smallette was convicted
we didn't get to it on friday's show but
he was convicted just at the very tail
end of last week on five class four
felonies for lying to police about a
hate crime that he staged
himself when he was walking around
chicago
and allegedly two white guys and maga
hats came up to him with a noose and
said this is magga country and jesse
smallett managed to hold on to his
subway salad i believe it wasn't even a
subway sandwich the story gets less and
less believable all the time and then he
survived this attack which turns out had
been perpetrated by two
nigerian boyfriends of his and that'll
that all came out good news on the
conviction there is still some justice
left in america if jesse smilet managed
to get off the hook for staging this
ridiculous
hate crime
as opposed to a love crime
if he'd gotten off the hook for this you
just think that truth doesn't matter
anymore we're completely through the
looking glass but at least the truth
still matters a little bit now not to
drag up ancient history
but all the prominent libs got this
completely wrong kamala harris said
quote
this is in 2019 when jesse smellet
perpetrated it jesse smallett's one of
the kindest most gentle human beings i
know i'm praying for his quick recovery
this was an attempted modern day
lynching
no one should have to fear for their
life because of their sex or color of
their skin
we must confront this hate peat bootage
edge while the struggle for basic hate
crime legislation continues here in
indiana
this horrible attack calls all americans
to stand against hatred and violence in
all forms bernie sanders the racist and
homophobic attack on jesse smilet is a
horrific instance of the surging
hostility toward minorities around this
country apparently it's hostility from
other minorities though and sometimes
from
the the people themselves who are
allegedly having the attacks perpetrated
against them we must come together to
eradicate all forms of bigotry and
violence which will never happen by the
way because it's a fallen world and we
don't live in the utopia of bernie's
fevered imagination nancy pelosi the
racist homophobic attack on justice
millet is an affront to our humanity no
one should be attacked for who they are
or whom they love again they weren't it
was just completely made up it was the
only guy that was attacked is the guy
who is and who loves in a way that is
apparently under a great right attack i
pray that jesse has a speedy recovery
and the justices served it was
maybe we all commit to ending this hate
once and for all kirsten yellow brand
ariana grande on and on and on
and on and on and on and they were all
wrong they were all completely wrong and
no one to my knowledge
has
acknowledged this or apologized and they
won't have to it'll just go away a lot
of them haven't even deleted the tweets
and then i over the past few days have
just been retweeting these people
because you know they were relatively
small to it so i just bring it back up
and see no shame it doesn't matter they
almost certainly won't be held
to account
the white house
was asked about this and jen saki says
people
people are learning
everyone is learning their lessons from
the smilet incident
since the guilty verdict are there any
lessons learned here
on rushing to judgment when a crime is
alleged i think there are there are
lessons learned perhaps for everybody
who commented
at the time including former president
trump i wish april ryan was here because
i think she asked him the question
do i see her somewhere or no okay
she just left where he said i can tell
you that it's horrible it's it's
doesn't get worse uh in response to her
question about the tri about the uh
about jessie smellet at the time uh i
would say that we respect the jury's
decision lying to the police
particularly about something as heinous
as a hate crime is shameful
instances of that need to be
investigated fully and those found
guilty need to be punished and false
accusations divert valuable police
resources away from important
investigations they make it harder for
real victims to come forward and be
believed you know if you look back at
the time it's also true and important to
note that accusations of hate crimes
should be taken seriously and they need
to be fully investigated
lessons are being learned by everyone
there are a lot of lessons to go around
except no one is learning
anything
now one thing that you should learn is
how to get a better rate on your
mortgage which is why you should check
out american financing mortgage rates
continue to remain incredibly low for
the moment will they stay at this level
in the new year i don't know you can't
be sure which is why you need to call
american financing lock into a low rate
now and potentially save yourself up to
a thousand dollars a month
one thousand dollars per month
potentially you can even skip your
january mortgage payment in possibly
february creating greater savings as we
begin a new year think of how much that
can help and then give american
financing a call
there is no pressure no obligation no
upfront or hidden fees just a simple
conversation around ways that you can
save without restarting your loan that's
right you can choose any term 10 years
and over so you're not wasting money on
years you don't need get a free mortgage
review today when you call 800-685-5696
or if you're more digitally inclined go
to americanfinancing.net
nmls182 334 nmls consumeraccess.org
gensake says look there are lessons
lessons for everybody to to learn from
the jessie smallett hoax there aren't
there aren't she cites donald trump
because donald trump just made some
vague political comment about how oh yes
it sounds bad or whatever
but
for those of us who knew
from the very beginning that this was
obviously bogus
we're not going to learn a lesson
because there's no lesson to learn
because we were right and these other
people were wrong
for the people who were wrong about this
they're not going to learn any lesson
they're going to continue
in their false narrative
how did some of us know from the moment
that jesse smilet alleged that it was
mega country in the south side of
chicago or wherever he was
that this was a fake attack we knew it
because
that sort of thing just doesn't really
happen
it happens in the fevered imagination of
leftists who think that the ku klux klan
is around every corner it happens in the
fevered imagination of lebron james who
when he leaves his you know
golden palace thinks that there are
klansmen everywhere trying to lynch him
but in reality those of us whose view of
the world is a little closer to reality
we know that that just just doesn't
happen actually
so that's how and the leftists who
believe that the clan is running around
everywhere trying to lynch all the black
people
they're they're not changing their view
actually they're doubling down
they're saying that even though this was
a hoax
don't let it distract from the greater
truth that black men
and homosexuals
are constantly oppressed by straight
white men who are trump supporters who
are perpetrating these sorts of attacks
to tune in for this false but somewhat
prevalent view
you have to look at those cackling hens
on the view
notably the fake republican on the view
anna navarro when it first happened i
think it was unimaginable to anybody
that that it could be a hoax
um and frankly you know i think that for
a lot of us it read believable that
there could be hate crimes because there
are hate crimes against minorities and
against lgbtq and it's not you know
kamala harris's fault or joe biden's
fault for cory booker's fault or
anybody's fault that their natural
reaction was to empathize with somebody
who we all at first thought was a
victory twitter's fault anyway
can we focus on the guilty part no it's
not our fault like i know that we were
totally wrong and the the reality was
totally different but it's not our fault
that we believed this obviously
delusional it was at the time it was
unimaginable that it was a hoax well
then how come many of us said it was a
hoax from the very beginning it because
it was unimaginable no it was eminently
a manager imaginable and it was probable
and it was almost certain that it was a
hoax from the beginning because none of
the facts added up when you considered
reality
the the elements of the story only added
up in a leftist fantasy even the fact
that the two nigerian guys who we were
told were white trump supporters yelled
out hey yo empire
because they recognized this minor actor
from a show that i had never heard of
until the jesse smilet fake attack
how
in your own head do you have to be how
extraordinarily narcissistic do you have
to be to believe that
to believe anything about this story
that that white
conservative trump supporters walking
around chicago even know who jesse
smallett is i'd never heard of this dude
until he perpetrated this hoax
and it's not our fault that we got it
wrong it is your fault it is your fault
that you
believe and peddle a false view of the
world
that is you you bear responsibility for
that you have a responsibility
to
perceive the world in a way that is
basically correct and if you're getting
things that are wrong you need to be
held accountable for that and you need
to discipline yourself to get rid of
that kind of fantasy and to learn things
you have a responsibility to learn
things you have a responsibility to the
truth anna navarro and what she is
saying here and what all of the other
hens are agreeing with and nodding their
heads
is that no we
shouldn't learn a damn thing from this
oh yeah you're so right anna navarro
you're so so right speaking of
make-believe stuff
every
month or so there is some new headline
that they want to change james bond
james bond is a british dude and they're
always trying to change that and so
they're going to make him some other
ethnicity
which i guess is certainly more
plausible than the other option which is
they want to make him another sex
so james bond is going to become jane
bond or something like that and it
always pops up on twitter and then it
kind of disappears or it comes up in the
news and then it doesn't really happen
but the producer of james bond barbara
brockley has now finally opened the door
to one of these possibilities she says
no james bond is not going to be a woman
but he might not always be a man
now i'm i'm no biologist
but i don't
i don't understand what so here's what
she says i think we should be making
more films about women this is an answer
will james bond ever be a woman i think
we should be making more films about
women i think bond will be a man
non-binary perhaps one day maybe
who knows i mean i think it's open we
just have to find the right actor now i
can't tell here
if barbara broccoli is being facetious
if she is peppered by this insane
suggestion so often that james bond
should be a woman that she says no no
not a woman he's probably a man
non-binary is that a joke is that taking
it into an even more extreme
area or is it not is she saying as i
think many people in the culture are
saying that no he can't be a woman
because that would that would be so
ludicrous but what if men and women
stop being like men and like women what
if we
what if we pretend that there's really
not much of a difference between men and
women and what if we pretend even more
absurdly that someone can be neither a
man or a woman but something some
combination or neither or both
what about that
james bond will not be non-binary
he won't be non-binary because nine
non-binary does not exist
i'm not saying that there aren't people
who mistakenly believe that they are any
of these crazy categories
but the category itself does not exist
it is not real
it like the
hate crime against jesse smallette is a
figment of fevered imaginations so james
bond will never be that
furthermore james bond will never be one
of these kooky gender things because
if the character known as james bond is
one of those kooky gender things he will
cease to be james bond because james
bond is
a dude with a funny accent who has a
license to kill and drinks martinis
shake and not stirred that is who the
character is
you can't go into the movie
and replace james bond with luke
skywalker and say that luke skywalker is
now james but they're just different
characters they have characteristics
it's not
possible even this line here this first
one is very politically correct look i
think we should we should be making more
films about women
but i don't think that we should take
the male movies and the male characters
and just pretend that they're women and
have the women pretend to be men
why do we need to make more films about
women
why why is that something we really need
to do
is anyone asking for that seriously i
know that people are saying that to
sound politically correct and very
socially acceptable but does anyone
really want that i don't think so
because whenever those movies come out
with some exceptions they bomb at the
box office
certainly when
you take a property that i guess is not
necessarily gendered
you know like
ocean's eleven i mean i think i guess
really i think ultimately that is
a man's movie or a ghostbusters or
something and they make it with women
and the movies are terrible
or you make some
you know captain captain marvel right
that was the one with the woman i've
only seen a handful of these marvel
movies but the movie was horrible
and so you might say well even the
superheroes are generally men okay well
so
this distinction is a little bit blurry
but all i know is this whenever you make
a movie specifically to make more women
movies
the movies bomb and they're terrible
there are plenty of wonderful women
characters throughout all of literature
and film and theater
but they're not the characters that you
just
chew horn into there and really try to
make a point i don't i think we probably
have
during the golden age of cinema we
probably had the exact right number of
women movies or women
characters or whatever i think we had
the ex i think when movies were good
that was the right amount and now that
movies are terrible we have some wrong
amount and you're not going to correct
that by being even more politically
correct
but
the the destruction of western art is is
way worse than just trying to make james
bond have purple hair and a nose ring
you know and
wear androgynous clothing
it's a lot worse than that
one of the greatest works of western art
ever in the entire history of our
civilization is
on the verge of being completely
destroyed or almost completely destroyed
by politically correct people in france
who want to wreck
notre dame
when you want to go to france that takes
a lot of
jet fuel and it takes a lot of gasoline
to get to the airport which is why
you're going to want to save a little
bit of money on that you're going to
want to get
get upside around this time of year
life gets a little more expensive you're
buying food for holiday dinners you're
buying christmas presents you're buying
travel to go see people
now that's especially bad when inflation
is 6.8 percent and that's especially bad
when gas is getting hit
just about as high as anybody else
you're looking at at seven dollars per
gallon in california well maybe you
should check out get upside my listeners
are making up to 25 cents for every
gallon of gas every time they fill up
how do you do it you download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now if you use promo
code noles you'll get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up which
means up to 50 cents cash back that's
using get upside you download the app
for free use promo code knowles canon
wles you get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank people who
drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks
per month in cash back there's no catch
the cash gets added right to your bank
account or you can use paypal or get an
e-gift card for amazon or other brands
go get the free get upside app use promo
code nulls get 50 cents per gallon cash
back on your first tank code
knolls
also
be uh be sure to head on over to daily
wire right now we have a goal of
reaching one million signatures on our
do not comply petition which would
provide a major boost to our legal
challenge because we are suing the biden
administration we have over 800 000
signatures so far that's a lot of
signatures we need your help to cross
the finish line
please right now sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply and then
share the petition with all of your
friends and family send a message to the
biden administration we will be right
back with a lot more
france's national heritage and
architecture commission voted on
thursday to approve restoration plans
restoration quote unquote
that will turn notre dame into a sort of
woke disney world
so
the first thing to establish here is
that while there is some participation
here from the catholic church this was
not a decision by the catholic church
this was a decision by the state of
france because at the time of the french
revolution
the french state stole notre dame from
the catholic church
and they have destroyed parts of notre
dame before the french revolutionaries
tried to take out all the catholic
aspects of notre dame and turn it into a
temple of reason you had goddess reason
and shrined at the temple of notre dame
so the french have been after this for a
long time and unfortunately it was able
to be restored in a more catholic way
but this is coming from the state
of france now the plans are being
overseen by a priest father
giles gildrun i don't know
and the plans include removing
confessionals
you know where you go in and you confess
to the priest
removing altars from the 13th century
cathedral removing classical artwork
removing the classical and religious
sculpture
and replacing it
with modern street art
you know graffiti and absurdism and that
kind of stuff
the
uh confessionals and other areas will be
replaced by
quote emotional spaces
there will be new light displays new
kind of techno light displays
there will be new sound effects they're
going to add sound effects to the 13th
century
church
and they're going to make these spaces
which are now not christian they're just
they're kind of they're emotional
they're there's an environmentalist they
want to turn one of the chapels into an
environmentalist chapel
they're going to make this more
welcoming
quote-unquote for people who are quote
not always from a christian culture
it's going to be more welcoming
i think that christianity is pretty
welcoming
you know i think christianity offers the
hope of salvation
to every man woman and child on earth
regardless of your race regardless of
your class or your wealth regardless of
your geography
i think christianity is the most
welcoming religion in the history of the
world and it also has the benefit of
being the true religion
it also has the benefit of having a
connection to reality and i know many
listeners to this program are agnostic
or atheist or maybe come from other
faiths and i don't mean to be insulting
or denigrate anyone at all but if you
have religious views and if you take
religion seriously then you know that
the claims made by religion must be
truth claims it can't merely be some
kind of subjectivist you do you and i'll
do me if you really believe
then you believe because you think that
your religion is true
and one of the wonderful aspects of
christianity which i believe is true is
that
it is extremely welcoming
to everybody you have everybody has the
hope of salvation nobody has the hope of
salvation in this insane secular leftist
religion that they are trying to
enshrine at notre dame
no one has the hope of salvation
it's this weird melange of paganism and
atheism and materialism
the paganism being the environmentalist
chapel
so that we can all worship mother gaia
or something like that
the sentimentalism being this the
emotional spaces where we don't put up
our sorrows and the sufferings of this
world that are inevitable in this world
and in our fallen world we don't just
send them up to god and and
pray for relief and have our suffering
be sanctifying but we just kind of try
to feel a little bit nicer or something
the emotional spaces or the lighting
effects
that are just kind of welcoming that
that really don't give us hope of
anything because we just think we're all
just sort of meat puppets you know and
all we exist to do is get some pleasure
and be entertained like clapping seals
and mixing metaphors but you get the
point
this cathedral
can never be a cathedral to everything
it can never be a neutral cathedral
it can never be a non-binary cathedral
it will ne and it can never be a
cathedral to everything it's gonna have
to be a cathedral to something
traditionally
as it was built one of the greatest
works in history it was a cathedral it
was inspired by and it was conducive to
the christian faith
every time that the cathedral has been
has been tried to be made into something
else it has been made much worse and
uglier and harsher for people
and the religion of leftism
is really really ugly and it's not going
to be welcoming to anybody so much for
the inclusive left it's not good
it's not going to be welcoming to
everybody it's going to
try to dim ultimately unsuccessfully but
it can cause a lot of pain in the short
term it's going to try to dim the
greatest and only hope of mankind
speaking of religion travis scott
he is that
what is he a rapper or a singer or
something i don't know again i had never
heard of him until
there was a real attack at his concert
at astroworld where people were killed
it was overcrowded there was all this
creepy satanic imagery everywhere
including the entrance to the concert
and some of the mottos and slogans from
the concert a lot of the imagery was
satanic and then people died and it was
really really ugly
travis scott now is facing a lot of
lawsuits about this and so he's saying
no it wasn't intentionally satanic
all that imagery no don't it's not what
you think it is
i am a man of god
i am a man of god he says i don't know
if travis scott is a man of god maybe he
is maybe he isn't
isn't really for me to know that sort of
thing
i'm a little skeptical of it given all
the satanic imagery
maybe he's just saying i'm a man of god
to cover his derriere because he's about
to be ruined with all of these lawsuits
but the the only reason i mentioned this
story i don't have very much to say
about the story of astral world in the
lawsuits the only reason i mention it
with regard to the notre dame
thing
is that i don't even want to call it a
renovation or a risk it's just a it's a
thing it's a degradation is what it is
is that travis scott is either a man of
god or a man of the devil
okay
it is binary you can't be non-binary
when it comes to religion
you're you're with god or against god
that that's in the bible that's where
george bush got that line from his
war on terror speech as we said you're
either with us or against us
well it's from the bible and it happens
to be true you're either with god or
you're against god and you you can't
really just be neutral i know that we
live in this time where we think
everything can be neutral and it comes
from
a perverted view of liberalism that was
really popular in the 20th century that
you can just be neutral on we have
neutral public schools we have neutral
public squares and
everything's going to be totally neutral
news media but you can't you're going to
have to have premises you're going to
have to believe something and it's
the neutrality is an illusion so pick
one or the other i certainly
certainly think it's wiser to bet on god
i would not i would not throw in your
lot with the devil speaking of
entertainment something really terrible
and devilish going on they're trying to
count cancel the
sweet baby or the sweet daddy who is the
leader of the sweet baby gang i'm
talking about my colleague matt walsh
matt walsh is
or was the number one best-selling
children's author in the country
as well as the number one best-selling
lgbtq author in the country he's a gay
icon matt walsh
and now they're trying to cancel him
target's website is no longer
hosting the johnny the walrus children's
book
amazon has removed the book from the top
spot on the lgbtq plus category i don't
think it's because the book stopped
selling i think it's because
they didn't they didn't want to keep
hearing all the gripes from leftists
and they might take the book down from
amazon
and i know a lot of people think oh the
best thing that could happen to walsh is
to get canceled because then it'll get a
lot of attention it'll sell more books
in the case of this book i'm not sure
that's exactly true because i don't know
really where people can buy it
but further even if it is true sometimes
if you get cancelled this happened to my
friend ryan anderson ryan t anderson at
the ethics in public policy center he
has this book when harry became sally
it's one of the best title books
especially on transgenderism or really
any book ever and so
the book got cancelled from amazon and
his sales spiked through the roof
and this would happen every every so
often okay sure that works for a short
time
but in the long run
the vast majority of books sold or sold
on amazon
if you're not on amazon you're not
selling books
in the long run this actually can hurt
walsh
and conservatives
so it's why once you know little
publicity stunts or something wear off
conservatives do need a separate
infrastructure
it's not enough to just keep you can
sell through these guys i think it's
perfectly right to sell through the
means that you can now but you do need a
separate infrastructure and complaining
and whining about how amazon is in a
neutral space isn't going to get you
anywhere one because amazon doesn't care
and the libs don't care and two because
there's no such thing as a neutral space
because everybody got to serve somebody
all right everyone's going to have
certain beliefs and certain things are
always going to be excluded from the
public square and acceptable discourse
this is the point of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now a number one national
bestselling book thanks to you and a
great christmas present so just just
going to mention that reasons to vote
for democrats my magnum opus without any
words is also a great christmas present
and you can still get those i think at
most places where you buy books but but
the point is the conservatives get this
free speech issue wrong a lot okay and
so
i think the left misunderstands reality
in much
more prevalent and much more serious and
ways than the conservatives
misunderstand reality but we must
understand reality sometimes too and
it's not going to help us to pretend the
world is different than it is
speaking of
sex
chuck schumer
chuck schumer
is
very insistent right now that on the
build back better agenda the democrats
stick by one plank above all and that
would be
paid family leave i got in trouble a
month or two ago because i mocked pete
bootaj for going on paternity leave one
i think it's very silly for any cabinet
secretary to take two months off of work
uh two i think paternity leave in
general is pretty silly
because i think men and women are
different and mothers have a much more
serious role
especially with really little babies
than fathers do
and i got i got a lot of flack for this
including from some conservatives
because here's what the conservatives
say they say michael you claim to be
pro-family
so you should support these
pro-family policies
michael you claim to be pro-family but
what are you you're just showing for
corporations who just want to make you
work more and you're just you're
focusing on all the same old dumb
talking points of the past 20 years
but we need to if the right is going to
have a future we need to become very
pro-family we need to be able to use the
government to encourage families
i agree with that point i agree i don't
i have no problem wielding government
power to encourage families but i don't
think that's what the libs are doing
here
i don't think that's what chuck schumer
is doing
you're telling me that chuck schumer and
the libs
who have spent the past several decades
the libs broadly have spent the last
half century doing their best at every
step of the way to destroy the american
family you're telling me that now all of
a sudden they're trying to help the
american family and we should believe
them and go along with their policy are
you insane are you charlie brown with
the football are you going to go buy a
bridge in brooklyn that's not what's
going on here they're calling it paid
family leave they're calling it a family
policy but they're the libs they use
political correctness and distort
language to mean it's opposite all the
time and what these policies are doing
and what they will do is not strengthen
the family but weaken them even further
there are plenty of ways to help the
american family here are some good ways
that the government can intervene to
help the american family drastically
reduce immigration illegal certainly and
legal immigration too this will hurt the
chamber of commerce it'll hurt what
corporations but it will help the
american worker because his wages will
rise because the american worker won't
be competing with an endless flow of
low-skilled labor good stuff that'll
help you take care of your family that
might help you too i know this is going
to be really controversial
only need one parent to go out and work
and maybe the other parent can stay home
and raise the kids we're not allowed to
say that anymore
and the corporate
establishment which is generally liberal
but it's backed up by a lot of
republicans they don't necessarily want
you to do that they think that boosting
gdp a little bit further is the most
important thing in america and both
parents need to work all the time and
you just got to ship your kid off to
daycare and by the way if you
if you are putting your kid into
a more economically quantifiable sort of
daycare system then you are going to see
gdp increase and you are going to see
the economy is going to look more robust
but i don't think that's good for
families i think it's much better for
families if families have the
opportunity for one parent to stay home
and actually raise the kids
that would be one way that we could
encourage it what about the the
declining birth rate in america
the birth rate has been declining for an
extraordinarily long time
and in recent years it's been
collaborated even more
i don't even mind having the government
go in and pay families to have kids
that's what they've done in hungary it's
actually worked out very well it
reversed their birth rate problem so
don't tell me it doesn't work it
actually can work i'm not even opposed
to that you'd need obviously safeguards
so that it doesn't get abused
but i think that's a fine idea too
what i am not for
is
the libs idea
of taking sex
out of
motherhood and fatherhood what i am not
for
is for
creating these sort of
government
mandates to give you more goodies
without necessarily having that affect
the way that american families are
growing what i am not for is pretending
that men or women and women are meant
what i'm not for is redefining marriage
away from what it has always meant to
some new idea what i what i am not for
is depriving a child of a mother and a
father i'm not for that and that's what
the libs are after and that's why the
conservatives need to be wise about this
be wise as a serpent and innocent as a
dove
speaking of
illegal aliens
governor ron desantis is wielding the
power of the state
to boot to actively boot illegal aliens
out of florida
yesterday's budget
i put in 8 million
for us to be able to transport people
illegally out of the state of florida
now we had mentioned and i said you know
it's somewhat tongue-in-cheek but it is
true if you sent to delaware or martha's
vineyard or some of these places that
border would be secure the next day that
border would be secure
but instead they're they're imposing the
results of their policies um on states
like florida who they love to hate or
whatever
so but we are going to provide that
opportunity and i think that that could
potentially make a difference
love it this is awesome the libs and the
squishes are going to decry this and
they're going to say
this is you have no right governor to
ship people from florida to the other
states no you can't just do that first
of all this kind of a policy
has a long tradition
in american politics it was always
rumored that giuliani would do this to
the homeless people he'd give him
one-way bus tickets and say get out of
the city and giuliani had other policies
too and it did clean up the homeless
problem
and so what's happening in florida is
florida's a very attractive state
it's not so far
from
the southern border
and it's got really great
government and it's good to thrive there
and it's beautiful and you can you can
have a really good life it's really
attractive and so people who are
violating our nation's most basic laws
at the encouragement of people like joe
biden and the democrats are going to
places like florida which have
republican governors who are saying we
don't want this to be happening and if
if i were running the show i'm sure
governor desantis thinks a lot about
what would happen if he were in the
white house you know we wouldn't have
this and we'd crack down more on the
border so what desantis is saying here
is no enough is enough this isn't my
problem you libs want it fine take them
here you go
how is this policy going to look in
practice i don't know but if if the
policy were
buy an airplane ticket for illegal
aliens and say go to illinois go to
california go to new york go to go to
i don't know any anywhere that's a
really hardcore blue state
i would support that policy
and then you guys deal with it
you want to deal with it then you deal
with it we're not going to do it here in
florida i think that would be a good
use
of the state
people
are suggesting this is lawless this is
way less lawless
than amnesty
and open borders and the programs that
the libs and the squishes who are going
to clutch their pearls about this are
pushing
good honor we should see this in every
conservative state in america ship them
all to the lib blue states and let them
deal with the consequences of their
policy
speaking of leaving places
chris wallace is leaving fox news
channel chris wallace has been at fox
news channel a long time he's hosted fox
news sunday and he just announced in
what seemed like a surprise announcement
that he is leaving fox news sunday
effective immediately
after 18 years this is my final fox news
sunday it is the last time and i say
this with real sadness we will meet like
this it's been a great ride we've
covered five presidential elections
interviewed every president since george
h.w bush
traveled the world sitting down with
francis emanuel macron and russia's
vladimir putin
and i've gotten to spend sunday mornings
with you
it may sound corny but i feel we built
a community here
there's a lot you can do on sunday
mornings the fact you've chosen to spend
this hour with us
is something i cherish but after 18
years i have decided to leave fox i want
to try something new to go beyond
politics
to all the things i'm interested in i'm
ready for a new adventure and i hope
you'll check it out
wow chris you're leaving a really big
show fox news sunday is a really big
show cable news is kind of on the
decline but still you know fox news
sunday is a very big property you've
been there forever so whatever you're
doing next must be really really big and
really important okay so let's see i've
got it here chris is going to
the cnn digital streaming platform
so cr chris is leaving
one of the bigger shows on
cable news
on the on the biggest news channel on
cable news to go to a smaller news
channels not television station but
digital streaming service
which is nowhere near the size of the
biggest streaming services on the right
now we're i guess we're probably the
biggest one on the right depends on how
you quantify it
i
huh why would you why would he be doing
that
he might have been pushed out his
contract might have been up i don't know
or he might have genuinely wanted to
leave fox i never really had a big
problem with chris wallace until that
presidential debate in 2020 where he was
so overtly and dishonestly partisan as a
democrat that it
it was unbearable chris wallace has
always been a democrat but he's he's
always had this pretense of at least or
and maybe he was really trying to have
some kind of neutrality
he was trying to be
disinterested bipartisan an equal
opportunity
interviewer
regardless about what chris wallace
wants or what he's excited about or the
inner workings of this negotiation
the bigger takeaway from chris wallace
leaving fox news after all these years
to go to cnn to go to the streaming
platform even
is that the audiences
no longer believe or want the pretense
of impartiality in news when chris
wallace was hired by fox news
it was because even the conservatives
fox news was at least
broadly the conservative news channel
but they wanted to have the pretense of
we're going to be totally down the
middle we're going to call it like we
see it fair and balanced we're not
really the conservative we're going to
be totally impartial you see this in the
law with something like originalism
which says we're going to be totally
impartial
about the left and the right and
conservative and
leftist and we're just going to read the
text in this very neutral impartial way
you see this in public schools we're not
going to indoctrinate people we're just
going to educate people we're not going
to teach them what to think just teach
them how to think we'll be totally
neutral see this in the public square
we're going to be totally neutral
between say religions or different
beliefs when we totally and that
idea of neutrality in public
is that's not the old way of doing
things that that was a really
strange phenomenon that existed for part
of you know the second half of the 20th
century but it's it's not
real people believe things there is no
neutrality whether it's on cable news or
whether it's in the public square
whether it's in religion wherever it's
anywhere else if you stand in the middle
of the road
you were going to be hit by a truck
speaking of there's been a lot of death
talked about in the show today you will
be hit by a truck so pick a side i'm
michael knowles this the michael knowles
shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the matt walsh show after
tornadoes devastated parts of the
country on saturday the left insists
that the disaster could have been
prevented through legislation is that
true can we pass laws that will stop
tornadoes we have to deal with that
today also major retail chains begged
congress for help in dealing with the
surge in crime i'll explain why they
should be basically out of luck and the
catholic diocese says that it's a sin to
try and change your gender the media is
treating this like breaking news but
isn't that what every competent
christian believes and with jesse
smallett's conviction there is a
competition to see who can take his
place as our nation's chief race hoaxer
one blm supporting doctor seems to be
auditioning for the role we'll talk
about all that and much more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]